[Music]
not until I've had my second cup of
coffee said the unfunny mom on Pinterest
that's not how memes are used take that
moms everyone's always every save
challenging for position ways with the
moms they are like oh we hope the moms
tune in I hope you never watch this your
most caffeine addicted or the most
alcoholic mom I think that the most
statistically likely to be abusive
toward their children like the
accusation that men are just the only
ones that are hyper competitive and then
you get on your wrist yeah like you get
on Facebook or pinch I don't know that
just stress would sign on your wall well
men are highly competitive about things
that matter by the way I didn't
introduce you guys it's good morning
good morning mine club by the way
hashtag mug Club Quarantine is the
course the promo code is quarantine I
get $30 off a little bit of echo where's
the snack audio wait I don't you sound
great mate we're flying
we'll be taking your charity today who
needs nets messy when you're flying
nothing but net is a phrase that women
are unfamiliar with because they don't
compete in the arena of sports well well
well well he's on a roll quarantine is
the promo code $30 off and of course
were giving everything away for free
this month and we're only two weeks in a
schedule less and then I spilled water
all over myself here and we're talking
about quite a bit we're talking about
Michigan we will also get into what I
think is the funniest thing I've ever
seen and I'm going to try and not laugh
I'll get to that in a second
anything else what else do we have let
al Qaeda come /schedule for all of the
schedule kind of we have a live stream
next Tuesday with a press briefing
because we want to do the job that the
media does not do somebody's got to pick
up the slack and I don't I don't know
what else is there something that I'm
missing I feel like I just keep getting
plugs that are added
that I need to make sure that I hit I
think you've hit just about router bits
did you plug oh that's that's right
audio wait is half-gay oh yeah a chicken
do you know rebel without a cause before
I show
he just went all the way through because
he thought it proved his masculinity I'm
not sure it just proved he was gay hmm
that's weird
but I'm not gonna yes and that sorry
that's fine yes and that's not improv
game my heart goes out to him right if
we it only knows we make a lot of jokes
about him we did behind his back and now
it turns out that they weren't really
jokes so we will be talking about his
wonderful Bryan Callen what else do we
have we have a kovat update but first I
guess this is making the rounds right
now this morning dr. Phil he's trending
because he talked about the need to open
the economy and I guess people are
really furious he's trending right now
on Twitter which let's knock that out
with mukluks quarantine let's watch 250
people a year die from poverty and the
property line is getting such that more
and more people are going to fall below
that because the economy is crashing
around us and they're doing that because
people are dying from the coronavirus I
get that but look the fact of them
here's the thing I want to see I want to
see it's kind of like Bill O'Reilly does
his podcast now no one wants to see sad
webcam dr. Phil he needs to be very well
produced yeah and Bill O'Reilly a llama
made a Jim Henson Muppet ear
like ham and Larry King should have the
same guy we can burn easier there's a
level of experience that comes with
having done you know the puppeteering
for writer king you just can't recreate
that i don't know i and you would think
there's a level of experience in hosting
a show maybe there where you would
improve but Larry King just bucks all
the trends I think it's a delivery
there's a little badge and I know dave
rubin loves them and they're good
friends but like i sit there and i just
can't watch it it's it's a niche there's
you a lot of people do you ever see his
interview with Tom Green no Tom Green
Freddy got fingered was that a mistake
I know Tom green you're not American
no I'm Canadian mmm deep bleeds in and
looks old at you
um what okay before here's also my
question for you guys we'll be taking
your chat of course live on Blais only
from Mudd Club members leave your name
because that doesn't let you enter in a
name before this crisis how much power
were you afraid of the government
wielding and has that changed at all I'm
sensing a shift in the tides and our
people know there's a little bit of an
overreach here even people who before
we're saying you know you need to stay
home and quarantine and not do anything
we should shut down the entire economy
now I see a lot of people going like
okay we're really a little wrong about
that when you try it when you arrest
people for kissing in public this is one
thing if I were to get arrested or you
get a ticket by a police officer for
kissing my wife on a park bench I mean
I'm not I'm not an exhibitionist yeah I
would just I would just I just go away I
would have sex with my wife on the bench
in front of it would be spite sex but
but then I think he would actually have
a legal case against you the point is be
in the record books it would be active
disobedience would and intensely
pleasurable for me so civil disobedience
at its finest
sorry wait about the gay thing I just
wanna make sure that audioline knows
doesn't feel slighted well when
everybody gets home and his wife starts
asking probing questions I tell you I
call you then go to a public park kiss
her on the bench wait for the police
officer and then make sure he has a body
Mena's Milton girl told Richard Pryor
pick your spots King
well you focused on the half game and
half straight also it's like a ticket in
a public park did you guys see the one
where there was a runner on a beach and
a cop like running up next to right
gradually pulling away and then kicks
the afterburners like the cops just like
ah hell this is embarrassing for my
power trip ronita awesome Wow like he
pulled away just enough to where the cop
realized oh crap I'm not gonna catch him
but it was still expending energy
yeah just kicked it in we're gonna have
my dad on here to tell stories and one
of the stories that he can tell famously
is of my grandfather who was named Dean
and and his son who was also named Dean
there's like 19 Dean he was smoked he
smoked
drank what are you looking for audio and
he's looking back like he's looking for
the looking back like he lost his
marbles and never lived I did I've lost
my marbles in Neverland what did you
what did you drop it
I dropped a bottle of topo Chico
flooding you know it's it's it was empty
you dropped the bottle of Mexican water
amidst a pandemic in a school that has
been critical of Mexico so really quick
before we go on with anything else here
is a clip we are going to tune in tune
back to this later in the show and you
can place your bets
I want to see if I can hold a straight
face ok no I will say this I have never
laughed this hard in my life I was
watching a special with my wife it was
one of those things was incidental or
we're watching you know yeah whatever
like the net the cue said like are you
sure you want to watch this like like a
second agent Schumer special it's ozark
3 there you go don't make me feel bad
about my decisions and it wasn't that it
was Hulu and then there was a 20/20
special on that Elizabeth all I want to
say granholm that was the previous
Michigan nah oh wait was a little crane
home Texas permission you know I think
she was Michigan Governor I don't know
wasn't Texas no is definitely Michigan
now it's Whitmer yeah
and it's there was a 20/20 special
because there's a film someone can tell
me there was a documentary from H on HBO
about fur a nose yeah it was called yeah
I don't recall but I recall the
documentary was excellent yeah it was
great more more of that this is going to
be a 20/20 special I used to like john
stossel's give me a break you know after
TGI Friday read and instead I was just
sitting there watching it and before
warn you I'm wearing disturbing pajamas
in this clip and this pops up in a
special that I I you ever have you ever
left accidentally on an inward like on a
breathe in and you die from laughter
tune back in you you uh allegedly you
can it's possible I don't know but but
it's tough to determine the cause of
know they label it kovat Oh
dang it bill I had that in my mind I was
about to no not quick and about not with
you in the room then he's half drunk
yeah serious alright can we get him
fully drunk place so here's a clip of
what I was laughing at at home then we
are going to play a portion of this
later in the show today just to see if
it was you know if it was a byproduct of
circumstances where I was tired right a
beer maybe two sometimes I live life on
the edge this is what went down last
Friday here you go and I'm not gonna lie
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
the context it was just interviewing
people you know drag races John from
theranos and this is so and so from
Esquire magazine me like this is Angie
Arriola
who helped design the iPhone and it's
what I can only describe I didn't watch
this now because I didn't want to ruin
it again ruin it for later as a guess
who character with male pattern baldness
a half gray perm yep Dame Edna glasses
clown makeup and in the first shot looks
like an amputee and he's just like you
know Elizabeth Elizabeth Holmes
right yeah with the half gray perm and
the Dame and the glass is named and I
think someone in the editing Bay must be
like but they figured it's so important
we have to thrust this is normal like
we're serious you know there's people
like there are people like Blair White
where you would say she I use she
because if I saw a lady looks like when
there's the barely passable and then
there's Angie Angie nipple by the way
the
is nipple and they never address among
is this I was I was actually it's been
such a weird month I had to check my
calendar like it's not April 1st right
this is a real thing
hey it's possible they filmed it on
April 1st and Angie is at home laughing
the greatest yes who troll of all time
I'm excited
is your kid does you can't you have a
half gray perm and hormone replacement
therapy I know buddy ok so I want to
take some bets here I think I think
Steven dies when he watches it later I
don't know I got $5 says he choked so I
thought his laughter it's like I don't
know that stuff I'll do my best to try
and keep a straight face someone thinks
he's not okay I don't think he's gonna
die oh I'm insulted I think I think he
will still be alive at the end of the
show I don't know but we will do it
after that's a hate crime that's a half
fake bill the cosmos is to you so I
guess you get back it's not we're very
careful about that also before we move
on to talking about government overreach
here I will be giving away stimulus
check because I don't well it depends
but it's 1,200 $1,200 and so just what
you need to do is follow me at at I
think latter with cotton in store
because someone else has Steven credit
Instagram yeah they stole it I'll be
announcing the rule where one of you
will just receive the check because I
don't need it and that's because you
guys have supported us here so you know
we give back with content and cash money
making it rain I don't know what this
means it's making it like I know what
that I don't know whoever actually does
this for money outside a Floyd
Mayweather prettier Oprah the whole
stack out of your hand I've tried this a
few times yeah I was gonna say you were
paid like I've never gone to a quitter
trip yeah and paid this way which by the
way very really quick trip they allow
you to use Apple or Samsung pay I'm like
7-eleven which is much more comparable
to a prison in Kandahar 7 I don't know
how 7-eleven still exists quick trip you
want to sponsor this show because yes
live for you well this is I will the
groovier you don't have to enter your
PIN number at all I know redundant
question you do it you're gone it's
kovat friendly at 7-eleven you have to
enter that not only that you can say say
if you want cash back or not
yeah still does that I know and
sometimes I I don't know any cash backs
just to make it longer to 7-Eleven out
of spite because I don't even want to be
stuck there hey look this guy is a
hairline that is all the way down to his
eyebrows let's see what he is no hiyo
Minnesota and Indiana and Kentucky this
coalition of people to say when they've
been doing no mention effective 3,700
added this week we're just wild guesses
like it was maybe twenty two hundred of
them were just people watching the ABC
special on 20/20 that saw Angie aureola
died laughing and hit add to count oh no
right so I want to talk about this a
little bit I know no one here is from
from Michigan but this has been a big
deal I think is sort of emblematic of
where the country is going
we've been remarkably tried to be as
consistent as possible in addressing
that the Verona buyers who flew I think
is the funniest a Chinese virus anymore
I think he made the point people like
all right like he moved on yeah you can
say something else you've moved on to
presenting videos but Michigan they've
had some of the worst laws not only the
most stringent laws but also the most
inconsistent laws laws that don't really
make a whole lot of sense and whitmer
yeah oh god let's see that man will
never go bald look at that's gonna take
a while
that's like a reverse guess who his
receding hairline is my full head of
hair amazing that is unbelievable
luscious Wow it's like he had plugs and
they overdid it I'd like you to stop
right about here what's this here that's
your ass here it sound like sod but for
your head we are like clearly you over
grass right yeah just pulls it back I am
jealous he will never I get look I got
this bela lugosi thing here going on
what your thing is - I can't get
haircuts right now right so my hair gets
long and so I go let me brush it back
and then I get the Nicolas Cage I get
the look of like the you know and then
you become psychotic it's terrible you
do really better
your eyes wide open yeah I'd like to get
my hair taken off Michiganders they
protested governor Whitmer and she
banned any and by the way I love how
they just arrest protesters in some of
these places I feel like that's a get
they're protesting the government
overreach and like well we're gonna use
the power of the government to put you
in jail for protests like that's what's
really employed groove to the point oh
so I can't protest your illegal action
because you've made it illegal
that doesn't mean credibly confused but
not really because you're a communist so
I'm gonna tell you it's an effective
technique that's the Chinese yes your
people do it well right yeah they have
two doors they have whistleblowers and
other yes
and you vote and then they just both
wrap around to the same place and you
just go into a pit that it goes nowhere
that's not fun spikes in it it has
spikes in yeah oh yeah I thought it was
just a repurposing of the hole dug to
China and so they were just like put
them back you send them you know a
couple of golf balls or whatever it is
with the hold of Sherman we send you
whistleblower you know what I love is
there's gonna definitely be some like
angry geologists in the audience is like
furiously typing out a comment it's like
there's no no it works there's a magma
in the center of the earth right you
can't dig through it he probably thinks
the earth is a sphere so flip here is
this actual Witmer herself
I can't let's go to first to spin in so
that you understand
Michigan what's going a little bit I
will talk about it tonight thousands
descending on Michigan's capital and
Lansing to protest the governor's
current stay at home rolls
[Applause]
blocking traffic honking their horns to
protest some of the strictest rules
animals outside they are traffic yeah
matter of fact they're the only traffic
also dramatic reductions in capacity for
stores big mall for customers profound
response have you seen people like user
it was actually article I think the New
York Times it can maybe bring it up and
said it's official the the quarantine or
the social distancing deniers are here
cars honking yes they couldn't be more
amenable to your demands in their
protests they're doing it from an f-150
probably with a mask on yeah if you read
the stories it says almost everyone
stayed in their cars a handful of people
got out of their cars and we're holding
signs and waving flags and the the thing
that they hated the most is that they
handed out candy to children and they
didn't have on gloves well how dare they
was quoted in two different articles
that I read is like the height hey but
he's running for president let Joe Biden
hand out the candy that's a missed
opportunity on him he set up a kissing
booth both he would rather but they
don't like Joe listen take the take the
W set up a kissing booth just do that
anything not maybe our culture will get
there some days just not there but we're
not there yet are we gonna normalize try
and push progress too quickly Joe you
know hood so Brooke was parents think
it's weird you know CNN you know listen
what they said right yeah they said
these are the strictest in the country
Yeah right
so people are I've seen people posting
about this on social media they're like
oh I can't believe these people are just
upset about social distancing no go read
the rules yeah yeah there's some really
really stupid you look at him it's not
on the most strict they are the
stupidest rules and doesn't shout out to
the sheriff of Leelanau County Thatta
boy where he said we're not gonna do
this because we're not going to infringe
their constitutional rights and every
single person by the way you can look at
the Donald Trump three-phase plan we'll
get to that in a little bit yeah it's
very reasonable
it's about quarantine those who are
vulnerable making sure they are not
exposed keeping schools closed not
allowing huge gatherings keeping them to
ten or less initially and then grab
Julie expanding and this is something
else I was watching the press briefing
last night and some reporter talked
about a leading question asks Donald
Trump he says well how are people going
to deal with the new normal you know for
example at a stadium if they have
hundred thousand seats it'll have to be
60 because no excuse me excuse me that's
there's not going to be a new normal
they're going to be back to full seat oh
my gosh can you believe this can you do
you understand what that would do to
people's business yeah you to cut their
profit capabilities by 40 percent
because of the sniffles I get it's worse
than the sniffles I'm exaggerating to
make it real but I don't really care I'm
not gonna apologize anymore
Kove it doesn't scare me that much
compared to the unemployment and
crippling effects do you know what would
happen to restaurants can't allow people
to be there to everything you know what
happened to colleges right imagine notre
dame imagine you team at an SMU oh you
can only have 50% capacity right now
sure but forever they assume that if and
this is by design just like the ABC
special they want to ask that question
so it looks like Donald Trump is
fighting against the current by saying
oh no eventually we're going to get back
to normal and they wanted to make that's
they want to make that seem like he's an
animal he's right of course no one out
there you don't run a business you must
have no idea how thin profit margins are
and people have to stay up all night
with turbo tax for all I know I don't
have a guy bill recommended people have
to they have to take great care and
address in these numbers you just want
to cut it in half what you [ __ ] yeah
well the WNBA is actually in favor of
this it would increase attendance what
do you remember when in 1918 the
pandemic killed millions of people
around the world how we banned all
public gatherings forever after that
point and had no football games and no
theater attendance and no restaurants
open and we we all just shut down and
died right remember that didn't happen
I think ullians of people around the
world if we didn't do these things the
intonation is that the opposite of that
you were man see sometimes I see what
you're saying and the same he'll talk
about doctor felt you listen you don't
when we're talking about a problem that
is all-encompassing and I will say at
this point the economic impact and by
the way because of the economic impact
it has an even greater toll on the
health and in the country when you look
at suicide when you look at mental
health when you look at people who are
more likely to develop addictions or pee
frankly were just more likely to become
unhealthy because we're not nearly as
active especially if you're arresting
people for going out jogging with their
wives in parks if you are arresting a
man for jogging alone on the beach
you are telling people that short of
having a home gym they can't take part
in any physical activity yeah
this is unreal to me at this at this
point that they want to suggest voci
great got it he's not taking into
account any of the economic
ramifications of just like you wouldn't
ask exclusively an economist what we
should do for social distancing right
he's an expert in social distancing just
like cigars we've talked about on the
show if you ask if you ask a doctor
right now I've asked this to a doctor
okay don't want to never smoke got it
what about cigars what about like a
cigar a day or like a couple cigars that
we read well you should never smoke what
are the actual risks of me smoking a
couple of cigars a week you should never
smoke what are the risks sadistically
there's actually a zero percent
mortality increase or of any cancers
combined the FDA releases a statement if
you have a couple of cigars or a week
but you should never smoke I didn't ask
your opinion I asked the risk so I can
make an assessment and make a decision
and right now we have very real numbers
22 million people filing for
unemployment I get it you like the
doctor you like to accuse Republicans of
being anti science but guess what we do
have to take into account the fact that
people have no ability to live at this
price so you can't only ask the doctor
is what I'm saying friend you need all
different kinds of input and make for
somebody this is the elitism from the
from the left they mock Donald Trump if
he has he has anyone on his board of
reopening the economy I think Tim Cook's
on the board if I'm not mistaken right
and look dr. Fox you like he said he's
one voice in this fight and you want him
focused on what some where Billy Gillman
saying my single no he's focused on the
medical side of this is that's exactly
where we want his focus we want him
saying what he's saying but he's not the
only person that gets to chime in and
say here's what the entire problem looks
like right we have a commander-in-chief
who does not turn over the keys to the
doctors in these situations for a reason
you can't know you can't do it because
otherwise he's gonna he's gonna look at
a situation much differently and say the
economics be damned we have to stop this
virus and that's exactly what you want
him to do but then you want the
economist to come along and say yes yeah
but it has to be proportional to
economists business owners anybody
anybody whose owners really
yes something crit people said bailout
people not corporations Oh a second who
employs people right who runs a business
yeah I don't understand what that means
if you do a lot of business that's so
that you can have a sustainable way do
you realize we just give someone a
cheque we know that doesn't work well
look at Native Americans my half-baked
lawyers buddy yang tries to tell you
like it works in Alaska hundred dollars
a month and they use it for beer money
live on that you just give people might
have jobs otherwise no you want to give
them the people who can make sure that
people remain employed so they have
something to do after this economy why
is it why is it that people who are
doctors are the only authoritative
experts according to the left but people
who've created a business from the
ground up and employment potentially
dozens hundreds there's no merit there's
no added value societal value there god
I just it's remarkable to me I do find
that this is an intriguing moment in it
I will say this to come you do both you
do both he's a lawyer so you did all the
schooling but he also started your own
firm I did right you could have taken
you could have been a clerk you could
have worked your way up in hopes that
you became a partner in a big firm
but you started your own and I respect
how hard was that really hard to do by
yourself hard every day I mean you know
I was fortunate to work with some good
friends to start the firm and to build
it up and you know to be where we are
and it's it's a it's a lot of fun to be
able to work with people but I will say
right now that the thing is really
unique about where we are is normally if
you were concerned about the economy and
you just were like you know I don't want
to talk about the prevailing wisdom you
would probably do it at work you do it
at a bar you did it Church you do it
with your buddies whatever it may be but
all the normal places that we would talk
about those kinds of things about well I
don't know if I really believe CNN or
governor Whitmer all those things we
don't have any of those instead the only
place that we're looking right now by
and large or we're allowed to look is
Facebook and Twitter and voices on
Facebook and Twitter are predominantly
hysterical and I will tell you it is
actually people in my position who have
the ability to work outside their office
and don't have to have their workers
come in during this time and can
relatively still keep their business on
that are saying well why can't you just
stay home but I will tell you that the
vast majority of people on the left and
the right when you actually talk to them
right now are telling you
weren't we talking about opening the
economy right and the reason is because
those people are suffering if you work
in hospitality restaurants all of those
different businesses and all the
businesses that support them right when
you're looking at the news right now
when you're hearing people say well I
it's very clear everyone's on board with
us keeping shut down until 2028 to kill
this coronavirus it's wrong yes yeah
flat out well you know what it's blue
people one positive of you know I've
talked about this if Republicans are the
party of the rich well okay listen you
still do need a majority or plurality
depending if there's if there's a Nader
plurality of the belt right what was the
other guy Ross Perot right no there was
one cap Schweppes but you need a
plurality of the vote so for Republicans
to be successful it is in their interest
to make you and keep you rich if
Democrats are the party of the port and
by the way let's be really clear not the
middle class anymore yeah the party of
the port the party the people who pay
47% of Americans who pay nothing in
federal income tax but they get federal
transfers that amount to a negative
fifty plus percent income tax right so
the party of the poor they've a vested
interest in keeping you poor so let's
think about this for a second right now
they don't want to ensure that the
economy can continue that people can be
important they talk about everyday
Americans they want to send you a
temporary check so that hopefully you
can be dependent on that check
forevermore
and then they suggest universal basic
income right now their solutions all
involve relying on the government yeah
and they and they and they absolutely
just [ __ ] kick the president for
presenting a three-phase plan that
couldn't be more reasonable and in line
with working-class Americans yeah and I
want to ask you one more question bill
you went to law school right you you're
very good lawyer he's a lawyer and you
started your own firm how many people do
you think who went to law school with
you who were also really good lawyers do
you think all of them could have done
that I think there's a there's
definitely a smaller number of people
who I even hear from my own classmates
the ones who are still working at larger
firms are working in companies right
they just say look there's a certain
profile folks who are you know kind of
have the skill but also the kind of
entrepreneurial risk-taking profile to
be able to start a business and
fortunately I have partners who work
with me who share that profile right but
there's a lot of folks where they they
just
have that in the answer is no he's just
being very diplomatic so long way right
to very slow get the segment compliment
and somehow I ended up looking like a
dick here's the thing one I'm gonna see
them at the Reunion if you virtually who
knows so I want to say that but but but
I want you to show up at that reunion
more Asian than you left them just yet
Susan Richmond that bill his name is
Bill o or my wuhan pin just lab coat
stethoscope there'd be like way demand
you started a lab safety company over in
Wuhan yeah about the same thing we've to
die I was I can't help but wonder if
this wasn't an election year what the
response would be from the left right
because what the the thing that we all
heard coming out of the State of the
Union was that the economy was just
roaring and there was absolutely no
foothold and if you remember the the
Whitner she actually gave the Democrat
response and all she could do is
basically go yeah the economy is good
but you know it's not as good as it may
be I don't know could be there was no
platform for the Democrats I can't help
but wonder if dragging this out doesn't
help them get their talk a little people
appraised listen she's she telegenic
she's relatively sharp but her response
made it was already Jindal rebuttal to
Barack Obama look like Winston Churchill
yeah the only more cringe-worthy moment
was when Rubio ran out of water in his
mouth
[Laughter]
somebody needs to tell them of the
cameras he's like this and don't come
see mama so okay really quickly by the
way Democrats also block an additional
250 billion dollars in small businesses
small business aides calling it a stunt
so again any way they could help the
businesses who employ you keep in mind
employers don't hate you they're
actually looking to try and because they
need to keep you employed in order for
them we're trying to make sure that it
went to more minority owned businesses
and women
and just serious could you imagine if
during the Great Depression we have more
unemployment and during the Great
Depression like wait we need to make
sure there are more colored businesses
now I understand that the problem should
have had more color business back then
but that's because there are horrible
racist laws my point is the priority at
this point when the playing field has
been leveled is to get all get all
Americans back to work and black
Americans Asian Americans yeah there
include Latin we're next will benefit
more than just trying to focus on a
suppose that that's saying we're already
working yes well you know I love that
half-asian bill is in a robe and double
monk strap shoes we just we just showed
you a clip this is probably gonna earn
credits but we can't even run the clip
we just showed you the clip from from
Crowder butts from Whitmer I don't
listen up watch it again I don't wanna
watch anymore with Whitmer so here's the
thing the laws not only were stringent
they were [ __ ] now for example term
I can't it is she forced all businesses
to close that have like you know
nurseries I mean nurseries plants yeah
different words for that yeah we should
huiling carpet departments had to shut
down entire sections of their store but
you can still sell you can still buy
weed unless you can just deploy one so
you can go out and you can buy yourself
some space man cush OG but god forbid
you try to pony up for a point set up
yeah just to show you this is the
priorities and you can't use your boat
in Michigan what's not so we have a
video of a guy who's getting arrested
jogging on the beach it's like I'm
walking here do I have to go in Michigan
not at all you can't even go out to the
water which is odd because that's also
private property for people people don't
understand this in Michigan when you own
waterfront property I don't know exactly
where but it goes like a slice of pizza
or like a slice of pizza like a corner
where a certain portion that is still
considered a portion of your property
and then its public you know because
you're out there and there's public
state-run I don't know the exact
terminology but here's the exception so
is there is there any you can have a
canoe or a rowboat but you can't go out
on a jetski it's like I just want to get
away and go out as a gas-powered in the
middle of the lake by myself with my
wife perhaps
on my Boston Whaler and you might see
the coastguard
yeah what are you thinking but if they
do pull you over in the middle of the
lake just tell them you're on your way
to get an abortion yes go on your way
sir Oh
abortion I like the big canoe industry
right now these big new Lobby is out
there you need a Coleman we gotta
there's there are two beneficiaries big
canoe and with with dr. Burks big scarf
loving it right now what else do we have
oh this is something else to keep in
mind too when we're talking about
middle-class Americans the reason
Michiganders are so upset and I don't
take political stances but because I
love Michigan so much was born there and
then have lived there for a very long
time and have so much family there I
might just need to step in and do
something to get this broad out of there
because I was a huge fan of Snyder just
because he was a wiener yeah but he
still was so much better than this this
lady right yes um Americans may not
understand this there's more coastline
in Michigan than I believe any other
state maybe outside a floor at more than
California well understand because the
it's fresher preps yeah and for if
you've never been to the Great Lakes
particularly Lake Michigan like in
northern Michigan for example Leelanau
County where the sheriff said hey
Whitmer just like that the vineyards
rolling down into this beautiful water
you know attentional I got married up
there and this is it is working-class
they have an unbelievable
disproportionate number of Americans of
Michiganders who have second homes in
Michigan I think of the number 265
thousand seasonal vacation house so a
lot of it's not like California or
Florida where you know you have this
beautiful penthouse right in these
condos these people have cottages in the
lake they go up they go fishing this is
the culture in Michigan when they say
you cannot travel between two homes
that's one of the rules right now for
summers you can travel out of state so
if you have yeah you tell some god-awful
reason to summer home in Illinois the
cornfields and the oil refineries for
some reason you can leave the state or
you can cut but you can't travel from
let's say Grand Rapids or Kalamazoo up
to Traverse City Michigan you're not
allowed to
most Michiganders this is what they do
they they don't go on vacation a lot of
them they have a small home cottage on a
lake somewhere and they look forward to
it all year they go there usually it
runs in the family my wife it's
tradition her grandfather built a home
with his bare hands
yeah up on Lake Michigan before there
were before there were power lines was
he Amish
I just build homes this man was a bomber
deer in World War two he built two homes
with his own hands he was the mayor of
Bloomfield Township or city supervisor
and he was a professor yet a PhD like
let's just get to building two homes you
could you couldn't pay me enough to go
on the second floor of a home that I
built and she tried to pivot and she
said you know what the U P right now is
gonna get set to get 30 inches so I'm
like seriously you just you basically
banked on the rest of the country not
knowing that there's a difference
between you be in northern Michigan
sorry that's why we forfeit our
god-given right yeah because of a
dusting yes but the U P is not the thing
going on right now most people are not
going that far they go into Traverse
City and they're going up like you said
to Leelanau County in places like red
okay so just stop missin F matters this
is why they've had these protests it
affects a lot of Michiganders who work
hard and play hard yeah Ted Nugent has
talked about this that is the culture
there's having a lake house it's passed
down through generations it's not super
crazy expensive as it is not it's always
more expensive now there's becoming more
popular something else do this is what
really bothers me is that um she claims
that Donald Trump this is whitmer
Michigan remember the name remember the
name folks Whitmer you're hurting when
it comes down to voting just whatever is
not Whitmer I have no ideals with her
she said that Donald Trump withheld
federal aid by the way we have no
receipts and then a band and threatened
prohibited doctors from prescribing
hydroxychloroquine oh you know she
probably has like a morning briefing
from Salon and slate because we're like
we have to go we have to team up against
hard Ashley Clark won because it seems
like it's a-workin she banned it
outright and then begged and lobbied
Donald Trump to send some federal
reserve afterwards
and then chocolate no there was a
miscommunication when we said when we
pro hits that we were prohibiting
doctors what we meant was send some I
really wish help yeah I really wish that
he would have been like you know I'm
really sorry we can't go ahead and send
it no sorry governor we can't do it just
to screw with her for like a day as it's
on its way there right with Bryan Callen
is that what I'm hearing this
this brought also uh this is something
funny to me she's clearly auditioning
for VP who's this on China revises Wuhan
death toll by up fifty percent six
percent death rate no he looks like a
comedian named Daniel Bryan Callen can
probably when he comes on I can ask him
that comedian who talks like this say
Dan something man Dan Savage man I don't
know but we'll find out who he is this
is completely irrelevant so here's
another finish she said she didn't have
time for politics and why don't people
buy this pardon me buy this [ __ ] when
people said like oh that's time for
politics you know as though everybody
doesn't have some kind of a political
persuasion right and then show so
because she doesn't have time for
politics and she's most concerned with
the citizens of Michigan a huge portion
of whom have second homes and now can no
longer use their jet ski she decided to
go on Trevor Noah's program and and wear
this hat because Donald Trump referred
to her as that woman from from Michigan
which clearly got hurt her coat I
assumed a lot of Michiganders have small
farms and goats so it was it was an act
definitely got her goat analogy here's a
but it's hard to talk with you or speak
with you and not ask you about the
comments the president made about you I
think you have a shirt that oh sure was
right that woman from Michigan an
extremely dismissive statement yes and
one that sparked a conversation is a
comedy show makes up for the lack of
jobs with the Edmond Dantes is that
facial hair is it difficult for you
during this shaving you get rid of it
whilst at the same time trying to deal
with a crisis I don't think any of us
has energy to deal with politics right
now
Oh energy all of our focus has to be on
meeting the needs of earth you just have
who are dying you just have the energy
to go to vistaprint and have a
custom-made shipping so you can go on
Trevor Noah's show and talk about
political weight he just didn't no one
remembers your name you're relatively
inconsequential now we will you're
welcome
now people remember who you are because
we don't like you so I don't have time
for politics but here's my shirt that
you can now buy it hala reelection guys
make a donation oh my god I hope I hope
she loses so badly I went for Donald
Trump I was so surprised yeah and
thrilled you know I called that one
wrong yeah big everybody did hey no no
not like me Oh big swing and a Miss on
my part I didn't take a shine down some
cover there and you just right I don't
want the cover I don't want the cover I
deserve to get my I want you to curb
stomp me and dribble my head like a
basketball like like like brakes of
Washington Wizards in other words don't
dribble so well like the Harlem
Globetrotter but Wizard level yeah I
deserve it I didn't take into account
Western Michigan and how much they hate
people like this in northern Michigan
like the sheriff in Lenoir County who
said no we're not gonna do that do we
support we don't have a link you know
what if we don't have Ryan Kelly I'm
fine moving and we can have them on next
week if there are there issues getting
him on skype yeah I haven't having
trouble getting ones okay well hey Brian
Cowen eat my butt so Wow my guys a humor
what I'm just kidding
did you just do do we want to do a
Gerald a roast this is the moment when I
go from number three to number two just
went number two nothing with you sorry I
joke check me I'm on you grace and paper
jawed son of a [ __ ] that was really bad
now you turn off my game
it was bad but at least it was long take
your square jaw and classic good looks
out of here he does have a square jaw we
actually do have a traffic report we can
okay you know what
before we move on let's go to a traffic
report right now with Thomas Finnegan we
want to keep you updated
[Applause]
[Music]
all right here to keep us updated all of
you on your morning commute because we
know that things change and they're apt
to change right now with the quarantine
is our on location reporter traffic
reporter Thomas Finnegan Thomas Finnegan
what do you have for us sir good morning
Steven I took the chopper out this
morning okay see a whole lot right yeah
what seems unnecessary to take the
chopper out so what are you saying and
why did you take the chopper well
looking back it was a poor decision it's
it's overcast yeah okay yeah sounds like
you're high up there okay well you know
what come on back down and maybe maybe
we'll call you back later and maybe we
won't
all right that's on the traffic update
here with Thomas Finnegan ladies and
gentleman
[Music]
all right I'm not gonna lie if there was
a if there was a low-hanging fruit of a
job go get ready it would be Thomas
Finnegan's job yeah yeah closely by the
weatherman because no one cares right
resources too but I'd do it I'd feel up
the helicopter and go up it'd be kind of
fun yeah it would be fun it seems like
me it seems very wasteful yeah with no
training yeah does not seem like Thomas
particularly fumble
no no spending on stations money well
alright hey here's an unpopular opinion
I'm just talking about this and then
they said don't talk about this but I'm
going to what we're talking about cops
and overreach of power okay at this
point and I've obviously backed the blue
I think they've been maligned often
particularly you go to like black lives
matter a lot of and you see that Dallas
police officers were shot because of
that kind of rhetoric and you know a
good example that is Mike Mike Mike
Brown right hands up don't shoot
he not only it wasn't hands up don't
shoot
he not only punched a cop he was
reaching into a cop car or the stood on
button reaching into a cop car reaching
for the holster yeah like I don't know
about you and this could be a blind spot
as a white person I can't imagine a
scenario in which I don't get my ass
kicked
yeah yeah I I if that's not the line at
which you forfeit your right to live I
don't know where it is right I don't
want him to die I just I just you have
to defend your sites not it's not even a
race issue I mean there are stupid
people of all races though those guys I
never approached a police officer
without even without going hey officer
ha look I'm here over here I just wanted
to know if I can give my wife we're not
sure anymore walking in and punching a
cop it's almost like I'm walking behind
a horse you know I just put my hand on
his ass Mike hey I'm coming around here
officer just want to make sure that you
know I'm here don't horse at all to get
unlatched no because they all want to
say you saw I also want to see if he's
OK oh yeah that's like you're gay check
is grabbing the ass no it's like walking
around you just it's not a grab oh it's
a guy that's a and you walk around from
the left like I feel like this is
something Joe Biden would say to justify
his baby I feel like it's something Joe
Biden wouldn't understand that I'm sorry
[Laughter]
but then you look back at all and I do
because there is a valid concern of
police overreach and most police
officers obviously are not interested in
doing that but we have seen some
instances like the man being arrested on
the beach like people being arrested for
kissing in a public park that's a real
problem
that being said I'm conflicted what's
going on there audio you and Maddie are
artists coming back here with me Audio
yeah he keeps calling back in like
please it's like you're doing that
what's that where you do the levitation
from your own body when you're sleeping
what's that called I should astral
projection a stroke so but I realized I
usually do tend to side with police
officers just because you see them get a
rough deal right a good example actually
this is something everyone's gonna get
mad right flowerpower remember that
famous picture with the the data do we
have that picture can we bring that up
the flowerpower picture with the person
the person putting the what was it a
daisy in the rifle of a gun right and
that's one of those things where I think
I'm the only person who when I see them
like I want that next frame to be that
Daisy being blown out yeah through the
person it's not only with flowers you
have any idea how much time that takes
especially because he's high a little
bit of the there's some wobble going for
anything missing it by a foot everyone
look a peaceful demonstration like
you're getting in that officers personal
space showing unbelievable I wanted to
be like a old film reel of that followed
by uh followed by he's off frame and you
just see just a puff of flower of pollen
I was like sorry
Oh warned you after the fourth flower in
the barrel of his gun they want someone
high on shrooms getting close to him
despite your turtleneck by the way that
guy that guy he was he was the head of a
drag theatre troupe and then later on
yeah later on died of that hates oh wow
apparently funny but this was clearly a
guy who was looking to make a statement
was and that won a Pulitzer for
photojournalism he's got nothing to lose
apparently right and he didn't know that
flowers don't stop bullets that's crazy
well no it's a terrible women shot now I
know that yeah I'm saying just why'd you
want to make sure cuz other I need to
clarify otherwise none of this is funny
or acceptable I think everybody knows
that get in good shot you got shot by
the HIV oh yeah which aids as you all
know HIV is a virus and ages the disease
AIDS is nothing to laugh at
virus is kind of funny though because
the virus is something you can beat so
and the HIV virus in North America does
not obviously we you know get your
treatment Dallas buyers club all that
but it's almost like the HIV in North
America considering the rate if you you
know if you don't have if you don't have
sex with strangers into it but you know
gay sex workshops are shoot up heroin
with dirty needles your chances
statistically 0% so it's like but it's
almost like the virus not the disease
doesn't funny but the virus is entirely
controllable manageable it's almost like
you fall asleep at a party and your
friends draw penises on your face with
sharpies and then you know cuz you you
you you have the Asian rosacea you fall
asleep for a very long time yeah the
sloughing off of skin cells results in
you I think I have a glow no they drew
sharp drew Stephanie so let's move on
we'll see update here know what's going
on a CNN there's a guy with a the guys
wearing Kareem abdul-jabbar I gear has
had a disproportionate impact on black
workers Greg Kelly I see a growing
number of cases deaths in America's
nursing homes why is that a new story
people in nursing homes are dying
Stephen people in nursing homes are
dying all sooner than the average
population what's the average age 87
that's past life expectancy they're
there because they're on borrowed time
at this point they should be great
doesn't mean that not every life is
precious of course we have to issue the
caveat but this is a story right now I
don't know if people are dying in
nursing homes from a disease that we
know 90% of people are almost entirely
fine if they are not old or already sick
yeah oh and here we have the color of
kovat color oh nice
that doesn't seem very colorful it's
really more of
a singular shade of covet is this gonna
be a continuation of this like racist
kovat claim that we heard the other day
yeah it is just gonna continue I already
covered that this week so we don't want
to cover it again a couple of main
reasons is they don't trust Authority
and they live in and black people live
in urban areas and so unfortunately they
are more likely to be affected oh that's
not racism now it's not like this was
now it could be you mean if it was
released from the lab like there could
be some racist person in China Chinese
people sometimes bill they're not
racists in China right there are some
racist helps we talked about that more
so against other Asians there's racists
everywhere but are they are they I've
seen a higher purport well come on you
know the Chinese people you talk to you
there Jared I actually have talked to
quite a few how many 10 now boys now
it's just a coincidence that they were
all racist by the way good a sworn one
day you said like sometimes Chinese
people can be he says it every day is it
he's just putting you on the spot you
know it's still I mean let no and be
confused there is a high level of racism
certain groups sweat dog and a wet
market I did but it tends to be against
other Asians not only but there is a
rivalry it's almost like sports teams
that we don't really have is white
actually that's not as bad as like for
example like in general Asian cultures
as it relates to anyone from Africa like
go there is again on a general level of
course colleges or Asians in America or
Asians can I mean it's just again when
you think about cultural you just say
Asians in care no seriously like there
yeah
because their age like the Asians in
Canada in America tend to be much more
tolerant because they've a similar right
American and Canadian cultural norms as
opposed to the kind of mono you know
cultural nature of China itself because
you think about all the people in China
are representative of a very smaller
number yes there's a lot of dialects yes
there's a lot of other races that have
come and been there but generally
there's nowhere near as much of a mix as
there is in America here's why we have
additional challenges
dealing with kovat from a genetic
standpoint right but the fact of the
matter is yeah they're there of course
what this is what crazy thing every time
you're gonna have any kind of negative
thing happened to a country like America
it's going to disproportionately affect
some race right maybe this race this
time is this race the other time
whatever it may be I mean this isn't
news right like I mean you know sickle
cell or you know Indian Americans if you
know tech support is no longer needed
new worry about stationary anyway regice
sent us a in an article from the New
York Post here okay McDonald's in China
apologizes for sign banning black people
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
when I find out that that sign was on
red on friggin Gerald's wine story they
just Photoshop that together right now
the ghost of crow is going and why dogs
are now excluded from the list for human
consumption they needed the German
Shepherds they're having oh wow pile of
German Shepherds and they're too skinny
I'm doing this live that is and we bring
up the actual source so I know this is
not fake right Chinese York Post I sign
it pull it back up for a second I want
to read back this I want to read the top
part real quick if you can pull it back
up in China apologizes for sign banning
black people amid chronovisor several
problems first off obviously it's a
problem right let's be clear primary
problem that you banned an entire race
of people
that's not cool for no reason but just
from a strategic standpoint what you
should have said was was nothing what
you should have when someone took you
aside and said this kind of racist
should not oh and just slowly pull it
down listen hope it nobody notices
bright just play the numbers game but
there likely wasn't a black person who
saw that sign in China yet well here's
the sign so we've been informed that
from now on black people are not allowed
to enter the restaurant been informed
for the sake of your health consciously
notify the local police for medical ISIL
[Applause]
I like that I like it's clearly a google
translate google translate
racism like my height my high school
Spanish class where I just used Google
Translate even though they told me I
shouldn't use Google Translate and I was
flunked immediately because technology
China okay let's go back to let's do the
update here really quickly I'm Thank You
red for making my morning of course
president Trump yesterday talk about
reopening America it's a three phase
kind of solution there are guidelines
and we can probably Bing up some of
these the first phase involves really
opening up kind of like what we've
talked about here in determining what is
non-essential but kind of starting to
reverse it goin okay more more people
can get back to work then not people who
are vulnerable the elderly
obviously they shouldn't be going to
work the first phase is still trying to
do a lot of work by compute what they
call it telecommunication where a
telecommuting
without telecommuting a remote work and
remote work so they still want to
encourage that gatherings of 10 or less
still so before any changes right now
we're states where they are not riddled
with this pandemic right now they can
implement these that still means 10 or
less social distancing all of those
guidelines apply in public areas no
gatherings for sports sports games I
don't know exactly else I don't have all
of it in front of me but you can read it
online couldn't be Bigelow's and I want
it yes take care which I want to be
clear about because the way the media is
portraying it is as though there are
doctors and scientists and then the
people who just want to open the
floodgates and let hell all hell break
loose right that's not what the plan is
at all and I guarantee and this is why
they don't want to
the press briefings on CNN they say this
is propaganda I was hearing I think Wolf
Blitzer could be John King I'm sure
whoever it is who whichever personality
void with white hair was on CNN at that
in a moment
whatever cosmic personality vapid
wormhole it was yeah they said we are no
longer going to air these press
conferences as long as he continues to
run propaganda the only purpose for
these press conferences is to inform and
assist the American people like
providing a three-phase plan that allows
22 million unemployed Americans to get
back to work in a safe and reasonable
manner
there couldn't here's why they don't
want to run that press briefing because
the vast majority of Americans guarantee
you including Democrats would read this
three-phase plan these guidelines go oh
that that seems totally reasonable yeah
yeah masks ten or less okay basically
just saying that people who want to go
back to work and there's no risk in
states where there is no risk they can
start doing that then you have Phase two
where it gradually increases it and only
when you get to Phase three do you have
sporting events and back to normal three
phases if the American public heard that
guess what this narrative that's been
set of science and doctors versus
someone like Donald Trump who knows
nothing about this and only cares about
the economy and giving all the money to
Jared Kushner it doesn't stand anymore
it doesn't hold water what I want you to
do is send these guidelines right now we
have them up but I believe CNN send them
to everybody send those guidelines to
every send them the plan and see what
they think and have them criticize
what's wrong with it is this what's
happening is a CEO Surgeon General yeah
he's talking about him the saying states
can reopen right now if they want to
right that makes perfect sense for you
what is going on in your state so we we
obviously give Michigan a hard time for
going way too far one way but states
like Wyoming and other states that don't
have a huge population don't have a ton
of these viruses right now and a lot not
a lot of cases they they're already
spread out as it is why would you close
them down right why not let them do
what's right for them
go ahead love the irony of how we've
kind of swapped back and forth between
well I think the federal government
should have done more they should have
exercised more power we want to give
Trump more power wait a minute yeah not
but not Trump but wait a minute but you
should have done more but now we're
gonna do it on our own and we don't
think you should open and you don't have
an unfailing power and
you're not omnipotent and you can't
control us but but we're gonna reopen
hey everybody go down and eat in
Chinatown right yeah the Blasio and look
well here's the thing too if you think
about it this way with politics bill
like if you give the states and if Trump
comes out and says look Rio you have you
reopened do exactly what you want to do
in Illinois and California and Michigan
and New York and places like that don't
reopen and everybody else does and we
found out oh no it actually worked out
really well
those Democrat strongholds and their gut
there's nobody to hide behind at that
point because he just deferred to you
and said do what you want we'll tell you
there on that of course I don't mean
this literally but we've talked about
this we've asked this question before if
at any point there's ever a reasonable
expectation of someone protecting their
rights by using their second amendment
yeah
if a man is out in a rowboat in white on
a lake in Wyoming then with his wife
fishing and someone pulls up and wants
to arrest him at gunpoint
that person should be met with the sound
of a shotgun not pulling the trigger but
someone out in a rowboat in Wyoming
there is no reasonable expectation to
walk in and tell that person you are
breaking the law right now it is and to
say otherwise is asinine
to say that someone is unreasonable in
Wyoming or Montana for saying hey listen
we're in a very rural there is not a
person for 50 miles this is my own
acreage we've taken precautions I'm
going out in the pond and right now I
can't think if it is amazing because if
you think of the policies that the
American media wants to mirror here it's
that of communist China it is all
examples they've pointed to South Korea
now they did some other things they pair
it up with a private sector but they
don't talk about that the tests they
praised them for contact tracing well
the way they did in South Korea was by
Daxing their citizens effectively China
well the way that was by lying about the
statistic yeah so if you're gonna tell
us that we're not doing enough because
we're not acting like communist
authoritarian regimes like China or
other countries our allies great
churches phones that explode so you take
some you lose some but South Korea still
far more paternalistic and authoritarian
than the United States because of a
history of their society this couldn't
be more reasonable this plan right ret
and in news flash governors of states
don't have absolute power bill I don't
know what the
yeah I wasn't doing the Star Wars I was
doing the et bra but a bill you could
you can print maybe speak to this but
you're not required to follow an
unlawful order I don't know are you yeah
no yeah no you're not yeah you are I
would argue till I die you know why I'm
gonna say yeah you want because when
you're dead it's not gonna matter
whether it was so here's the practical
thing right i mean i mean people
enforcing the law not the citizens look
I'm gonna tell you right now I'm gonna
give you an unlawful order as let's say
let's say the sheriff tells his deputy I
want you to go and do this thing right
and the deputy goes okay I'm gonna go
out and do it and a citizen says I'm not
gonna follow it and they go nope you
know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna pull a
gun on you cop you're gonna get Rachel
divided here half of me agrees with
Gerald know what he was saying is for
example like the sheriffs in Lenoir
County Genesee County yeah if the
sheriff's can say we're not going to
follow the governor's decree right now
correct or police officers what he's
saying it can refute now that probably
there might be consequence their job
yeah just sheriff's out there because I
know we have a lot of sheriffs who are
fans look at what they did I'd like to
see more sheriffs out there saying no no
no we're not going to arrest
husbands and wives for kissing in public
we're not going to arrest people for
jogging on the beach that's something
that sheriff's can do now there can be
repercussion so so there's different
aspects one there's the the autonomy
that officers have about whether to
consider something to be an offense in
the same way that there's a
prosecutorial discretion right how is it
that we can decide well we're just not
gonna always prosecute these crimes well
regardless of the evidence you just
decide it's not important to do now the
other aspect of that is this I think
this is what you were getting at I was
giving a [ __ ] earlier Gerald but with it
but the point is there you're very well
there you are a if you are a sheriff or
a mayor or a governor and you decide to
disobey the law there's no part of the
Constitution that says well if you feel
strong enough about the law you have
just disobeyed there will be
consequences from it especially if it
proves to be sure to order you'll have
two questions we're probably gonna go
overtime today so stay with us of course
if you're watching
I think we go overtime on the place I
have a burp nose wish I didn't talk look
at me say what the reason that I brought
that up was because in we have an
authoritarian some kind of an
authoritarian overreach what we depend
on is people not following unlawful
orders that are enforcing the law that
is this safeguard that we have from
somebody in Michigan let's say that she
went even further the only safeguard we
had is the sheriff's going no we can't
we're not gonna go around and enforce
this law rather than the people rising
up and banding together against it
exactly and that's actually one of the
things that is in history has born
itself out you see sheriffs in a lot of
different instances throughout American
history who have stood up in other other
political figures as well who have stood
up and said I'm not gonna follow a
certain rule and they have put
themselves at risk because it worked me
later determined that they were wrong
but without that test and that's the
thing is I do want to impress upon why
it isn't lawful because by doing
something that's not lawful it shows how
much they're actually risking yeah to do
what they think it's right because
without having done that thing they
won't lead to a legal challenge or they
won't read and punished and then have
the forum to be able to take it to the
court and resolve it in their favor so
it is unlock yeah it is a big risk right
they're doing it for the people for the
right thing they do I mean by the way
let's be really clear your active civil
your active disobedience if you are an
officer yeah is just not arresting a
father for pushing his kid on a swing
yeah exactly
take that all the whole bar that's a
local heroes story okay that's the local
news need a bailout so they could
benefit from it they want a few clicks
Uncle Sam's none the wiser
when she's already getting sued by the
way the the Michigan Governor she's
already being sued oh yeah I believe for
long right now so it's like happened
overnight say it again for lawsuits
I'll get us to clean under the best it's
like a Wuhan lab under there no I just
mean that I coughed yeah what do you
mean um by the way I hit the
notification bell hit all notifications
if you are subscribed because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot and
of course do join my club $30 off is a
promo code quarantine I can't remember I
was going to say something I don't
remember what it was but I would like
there some evidence to suggest that oh
that was I was gonna ask you so police
officer for example let's say in
hypothetical scenario let's say me and
an employee here use the registered sex
offender search to find pedophiles who
live on corner lot so that we don't shut
the neighborhood and honk near their
house late at night would a police
officer be within his rights to for
example give me a warning rather than
any kind of an official infraction they
have they have discretion to decide
whether you're actually violating the
law or not would that be honking at
pedophiles houses corner Lots illegal it
doesn't sound like it okay porn is
sounds like a date johnny-boy Friday
night we know what we're doing / we're
gonna stay up yeah they're gonna start a
trend question what uh when did the
Lieutenant Governor in Pennsylvania come
from the UFC I mean look at that's true
yeah could be a biker guy look at the
terrible beard and clearly he's able to
shave his mustache so he deliberately
got this spatula beard but angular what
is this talk about a race to the middle
clam with the stay-at-home order uh
Pennsylvania governor first I'm gonna
throw it overhand right why is it a
badge of honor right now to not take
care of your facial hair and dress
poorly for interviews no he is taking
great care oh yeah
that is premeditated is on purpose that
is walrus cheek yeah obviously shaved
the mustache he left the beard he
reminds me of a french-canadian who got
things a little late like he just got
Orange County chopper and he's trying to
look like the Tuttle's and that's like
it doesn't work we
the egg-shaped head yeah there was a
funny story that there was a judge a
state court judge who just went off the
rails and some lawyers because he was
like guys you're at home your clothes
are at home the dress clothes you would
normally wear to court so if you show
off oh one more time in a robe I will
hold you in you ran out of pants just
put just sit down at the desk and put
the shirt on yeah I mean I'm wearing a
shirt under this robe I know he refused
to wear the robe he didn't want to come
on in half-asian bill I want you to have
as much fun as the rest before the show
by the way some new evidence as far as a
quick story to get to people are
starting to accept the idea that the
virus likely came from Wuhan lab which
you talked about on this show but
because I'm not Asian I was like well
let's not spread conspiracy theories you
know only Washington Post's corroborated
me last night that's fine but you were
saying this weeks ago yeah how do you
know this because you told us before our
city went into lockdown you tell us
before the National order I actually we
have we've made a very stupid move he
was like hey there's gonna be a national
stay at home I always forget the name
stay at home order yeah please take care
shelter in place that's right take care
of whatever you need to and johnny-boy
stocked up on gas bring the gas cans in
here do that so we can show people yeah
I want him to bring him in we stocked up
on yes yeah we thought it'll be a gas
shortage it's literally the cheapest
most available some buying wet wipes I
know that's for toilet paper stores yeah
yes there's a toilet paper store here
our toilet paper stores exclusively yeah
and we drove past and you know what I
think that my love for a quick trip
blinded me it did youdid which by the
way they still have water at quick trip
they still have some toilet paper at
quick release time quick trip sponsor
this show I hang out I'll be out Brooke
I all want to eat at your locales Oh
only your roller food I'm at a roller
food I made that mistake this you did
after this
home order which I don't know which
livestream we were doing but I went to a
quick trip and ate one of those beef
what is it buffalo chicken and cheese -
nobody really know yet sitting in the
roller and I asked the guy I said I was
actually pressured to do it it was peer
pressured by the clerk at Kwik Trip
that's called put on the red chair red
cam because pretty near put on the
carpet yeah it's not a fire hazard all
right we literally came in I did let her
with creditor burned down and we thought
nothing but gas shocking we had we had
to make a call and we made the worst
possible decision well your wife
actually tweeted me when you got this
information she's like hey I'm just
saying like this you sweet text yeah
you're right sorry no yeah that's a big
difference yeah she's gonna go incognito
with a reply this egg it's like I wanted
to make sure they kept it on the radar
so I put it on the church bulletin next
to guitar lessons so you know you know
why I know right about the I mean like
every time I yeah I would you know what
I tell you and you guys think it's a
joke why do you think that I nice pie
wouldn't be that connected with me you
look like the fish in Super Mario World
- under what the under water you know
well you should have warned me about the
gas so uh on turns out they did now let
me ask you this do you think it was just
an accident or do you think if this was
some kind of plan to create a
biochemical tool I'm very convinced that
this was part of an increased ramp up to
study these particular viruses in a in a
facility that was not prepared to take
the type of safety measures and
precautions thank you yeah that would be
required to keep it safe yeah and when
you increase the study of these types of
diseases you increase the risk that
something is going to happen and why
does it look more natural again these
studies that are not coming out and the
evidence that's coming out as people are
studying disease it's clear that it
wasn't like someone tinkered in a lab
and put it together and then like went
out on the street and just coughed it on
somebody right but that
the testing of different animals as they
are working on these coronaviruses like
prior SARS which also had similar origin
that's what's most sad to me is I can't
make SARS jokes anymore yeah I mean well
when SARS 3 comes out son of SARS you
know yeah I mean there's we're gonna
have more of these and the problem is is
when you have a place like China and a
government like China who's not a strict
and then they have the other kind of
circumstances that go along with it
bringing all these animals together
there's literally no worse place you
could put a coronavirus studying lab
than in Wuhan right in a densely
populated a you know what it didn't
happen last year it didn't happen that
year before but this was the year it all
came together at once yeah it was like
there screwup leap year so um I've also
read and I cannot corroborate this but
there also is some circulating
information right now at the time of
this broadcast which is Friday morning
that someone who worked there may have
been selling the animals to wet markets
to make extra profit after they were
done with some of these experiments oh
wow so I don't know if that's true or
not but it makes sense good you know
think about this for a second the Great
Wall of China right breach three times
you know how they bribe the guy they
spend all this infrastructure and
technology and creating this workforce
and having everything be so regimented
that they often don't instill the
morality needed to make that work now on
the flip side we require a moral Society
to be a free society that's why the
fundamental building block needs to be
the nuclear family and then we believe
in local churches and communities and in
local government and then state coming
before the federal government but the
same thing you know for you to have for
you know the Great Wall of China to work
or that lab to work you got to make sure
that no one's you know just having their
palm grease Letton I don't know which
one the Mongolians in whichever
depending on which instance we're
talking about or selling the dog to a
local wet market to make a couple extra
you know but yeah well I mean it that
very least can you just not put it in
the middle of a densely populated city
of ten to 15 million people yeah that
that maybe is the first place to start
while you're working out your protocols
for safety and my the only one who's
always amazed though whenever I see like
like Japanese countryside I'm like
there's countryside you know it's just a
shot western New Jersey is beautiful
yeah I know it absolutely is
people are like oh no I just thought it
was hacks and oh yeah whatever but now
it's no I mean it is actually like the
other parts of the country yeah and you
fly into like Narita the airport yeah
it's a way way way outside of Tokyo
right fly over the countryside the
mountains it's beautiful right I didn't
know that but wait wait you said West
New Jersey and that's what I'm saying
like in the same way that like outside
of Tokyo everyone thought no they think
Japan right that's what's depicted all
the time but west like yeah I was like
oh there are areas near Cincinnati that
are beautiful and then of course the one
exception which can't be argued as
Illinois there's nothing good there
Chicago under the rain and pick your
poison do I want to be in Chicago no but
then I'm in the rest of Illinois so yeah
just move to another state finally this
is something I know so we were talking
about this on Wednesday we're gonna get
back to again we've placed our bets as
to whether I can make it talk about it
without laughing I don't know if I can
do it you're doomed but this is
remarkable so on Wednesday we covered
that story from ABC News about Donald
Trump defunding who the rails
organization right and I just read a
statement from someone in China so I
again this is happening live and I'm
reading a statement about how
disappointed some Chinese
representatives are in the United States
no longer funding who this was at ABC
News then when I went home I said wait a
second wait a second wait a second was
that what's the guy's name lil Jan Zhu
Li Jiang's outlet saying wait did I just
read a quote on air without even
realizing that was the foreign minister
on ABC News who they were quoting to
condemn the president who spread the
rumor that coronavirus was started by
American soldiers and then I ran a
couple of searches New York Times
Bloomberg Washington Post yeah all of
them in condemning Donald Trump quote
that the foreign Chinese minister who
blamed coronavirus on the United States
I couldn't believe that it didn't I
didn't hit me in time so to the point
where I then went on Twitter to go see
Lygia out can we someone read it for me
Lee Shao Shang what is it saying
Xiao Lu Zhang Xiao Zhang Xiao Liang so
it sounds like you're too Americanized
so let's go Shang sarana speak American
it affects my blog big Chinese I went on
Twitter I went on
Twitter he blocked me he's already
blocked me for retweeting him saying
like actually and all I did was say
actually coronavirus wasn't started by
American soldiers he blocked me that's
all I guess you are making the router on
the country's lists but I think I need
to make some phone calls to writers and
editors because either they do not know
that they are quoting a communist
propagandist who blamed the virus on
American troops or they do know and they
ran it anyway because it would rather
side with a communist propagandist
against President Trump and by the way
could there be any more of an indictment
on the World Health Organization than
looking to someone in China for a
statement and using the propagandist
Alex Jones was kicked off of you for far
less far less not saying I agree with
the conspiracies at all but I'm saying
could you imagine this guy was some kind
of American alt writer there would be an
article in New Yorker so fast would make
your head spin with a picture of Philip
DeFranco right next to it it is unreal
to me that I went through every major
source and they include a quote from the
Communist propagandist who blamed
started created circulated the rumor
that kovat was created by American
soldiers and the media not one or two
sources are entirely complicit these
people are not your friends you cannot
trust them the press isn't the amount of
the enemy of the American people just
everyone who's working for it right now
that's a pretty large group of people
there couldn't be a more unifying factor
for American people right now than to
say that China has historically been a
very difficult place for people to live
and to have any kind of freedom
whatsoever right to say that they've
been oppressed that's easy and that the
w-h-o is completely in bed with China
it's obvious this is a fight worth
fighting right if you don't like Donald
Trump pick your spots better because
this is an easy one for everybody to get
on board and say neither one of these
guys China or the WHI worth defending
they've done some really bad stuff and
it's cost tons of people their lives
probably hundreds of thousands of people
lost their lives because China life
would be very different if they were
apologetic or yeah Rossetti's are bad
start you blamed it on American soldiers
for crying deflecting the bleep American
military who knew it was gonna happen
it's gonna come out III just it's been
at a loss for words this week honestly
like you don't think it's it's ret No
I think that I think that the meat not
saying they're actual communist though
some of them but they're communist
sympathisers through their actions ha
talk about they talk about vetting
sources and how important news is in
this era of blogging really cuz bloggers
make mistakes like I've seen a lot of
typos I get it I assume some of them are
dyslexic but your source when you talk
about vetting is an actual communist
propaganda so yeah run that it's got to
be true do you not have a copy editor
nothing with the billions of dollars
over there in New York Times NBC News
are you too busy setting up whitewashed
late-night sets where they use the same
jokes like Seth Meyers and Stephen
Colbert I am just amazed that this is
what's going on right now and I'm amazed
that you find yourself surprised that
Donald Trump's approval rating is going
up at Americans don't trust you hmm
maybe because you quote Communist
Chinese propagandists while telling them
to eat in Chinatown because all is well
understand from fault
it is remarkable to me okay we are going
to come back after this we're gonna go
to a quick commercial a commercial for
black rifle coffee where I give you some
coffee tips and we will come back place
your bets as to whether we can make it
through the Angie areola the BBC News
gender-bender special without laughing
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
start your day like a patriot go to
black rifle coffee calm slash Crowder
today at least what you do online is
your business protect your business with
expressvpn steven crowder here with
coffee tips sponsored by black rifle and
mug club it's a match made in heaven
so today we're going to be using the
black rifle Chemex 10 cup Chemex I'm
gonna take my filter I put that on the
side of the spout so it allows airflow
grind the beans fresh beans really
important whole beans black rifle ship
some freshly roasted to your door makes
all the difference in the world
what the paper filter that rinses out
any like paper particles especially if
it's from China and it warms the vessel
and I cannot stress to you the
importance of a good dry to spend money
on a good bird rinder that'll make all
the difference in the world because
consistency is key we ended up with
about 34 grams grab your calculator
what's 34 times 16 half-asian bill let
me know that is 544 milliliters
grams simple I am going to be pouring in
544 milliliters of water I'm gonna bloom
the coffee and what does that mean you
want to get everything wet and it
releases gases that's why you'll see
it'll look kind of like a souffle do you
want good coffee or you want to drink
cheap swill souffle is not that bet you
want to aim for a three two and a half
to five minutes steep time so really
simple good coffee what do you need
water between 195 205 8 grams for 5
ounce cup and you want it to sit in
contact with that coffee for two and a
half to five minutes ideally three now
I'm gonna pour the rest of this coffee
get it up to 544 and now all I do is let
it drain and three minutes and 50
seconds on the button is where you can
discard the filter and there you have it
block rifle coffee calms Flash Crowder
enter the promo code Rotter you get 20%
off they roast your coffee beans to
order I grind it right before I make it
guarantee the best cup of coffee ever
it's it's a world of difference let me
pour it and the test that really matters
try that on for size what I don't really
drink coffee
[Music]
I don't know what that mean I'll be
right back I don't know what that means
do that we'll be right back to come back
back with the show okay go go so I
remember we had a standing order at Fox
to never talk about that Bill O'Reilly
freak out so I did it at every
opportunity not on the network because
it's how can you not address it it's so
funny I think about this funny of a
freak out as you can think of it is if
you just gotta own it if your bill just
be like yeah I was pretty funny right no
no never talk about it no really he
should have he should have but it would
have gone away yeah I know but he still
makes a point don't you just say that
you can't talk there's the video
evidence bill also said he also makes it
fun to send you unsolicited pictures
like show it's a family show hey before
we actually do we do have one chat here
we have for several but we'll do this
one here grant a from Michigan living in
the Whitmer land but thankful at least
to be working from home so I can stream
mug club in the morning thanks for the
extra content this month guys Crowder
what's the biggest thing you miss about
Michigan there's a capital M yeah miss
oh it was otto correct and they I now
know your wife's pet name so the thing
that I miss most in Michigan it probably
is just just summers by the lake and I
miss the beer for sure Grand Rapids -
fantastic yeah weird few rocks are
hosting this show I know that's what
he's thinking about
he's saying about you saying we got fun
memories they have one more to read
that's fine yeah no no let's go - you
said multiple chats yeah okay if there's
anything juicy that I need to sink my
teeth into oh no would you so the
closest thing we have right now I mean
it's juicy uh everyone buckled down for
one more hour
let's go hit it let's see so Chloe asked
what are your opinions of women
enlisting in the military huh also which
Bond film is best I don't know how those
yeah they watched my backer for the
first time the other day the worst
listen Chloe you get one question he
gets a genie and wishes for more world
yes so brilliant I think women should a
list I have no problem with women
enlisting in the military provided that
they aren't in violent combat roles if
they don't meet the PT garments yeah
absolutely I don't and I don't think we
should be lowering them I think we
should consistently be raising please
yeah sorry police and military what
about this question grabbed you Wade and
said this this is the question
something about moon right yeah okay
okay so now we can go back and I won't
watch this just so you guys everyone can
remember I was just minding my own
business special on Elizabeth Hall and
theranos pops up and ABC just thrust
this before me and acted like I
shouldn't find it absurdly funny and
I've never laughed this hard in my life
so what we're gonna do is you'll see how
this started and then we'll see if I can
watch it now and keep a straight face
all right play the clip say it's now
like I had to Google or you could die
from I binged if you inhale suede a
spasm in my back all night I was
breathing air just and then and so you
shirt like there's a guy who I knew when
I was a teenager who laughed like that
and I hated him so then there is I hated
myself but I couldn't stop laughing so
we're gonna watch this today to see if
the idea of Angie nipple surd stage
names I confused her with Naomi nipple
oh yeah back in my head okay so do we
think we can make it through this
without laughing at no no do it what do
we have over the bets
I bet five dollars you would die okay
right so you're still alive but there's
now gas cans next year this says that
light guy he says it like Donald Trump
yes you're saying I knew some great
people and now they're dead they're dead
they're dead you're number one Gerald is
number two I'm number three okay I've
either Gerald leaves I go up to two or
you leave I go up to two all right
okay so start watching this again and
see with a straight face with Angela or
Anna areola all right
who's she selling you on the mission
watching a dragon how did she come
across she was definitely selling me on
a vision for what she wanted to socially
disruptive blood testers and making it
something that was much more accessible
than it's ever been
so you joined positrons oh it's right we
can't pause others from Apple to join
their nose like it's not as funny who
had helped design me and I was very
curious unfortunately I've got 15,000
shares Apple but why you filming
Elizabeth was very curious about Steve's
attire and I explained to her that
there's 20 minutes come in this just
happens line manager apparel you're
still there still more of down who you
see me I don't know but honest says
Elizabeth's transformation didn't end
there her voice what she could figure
out a surprising likely posture a few
thousand dollars to get these are they
gonna bring bag honest fake wedding time
speaking of surprising no good because I
remember the next part and I don't think
I remember she like they only put funny
as they only bring Anna areola on the
pot calling the kettle black they're
like I know how to keep in character
guys this is clearly when they want it
[Laughter]
looks like it looks like our Bob Ross
wig when we totally Earth Day member
glasses and the you can still see some
stubble and clown lipstick and the I
don't know it's the first scene when I
first saw it I thought Angela Anna
nipple was an amputee because that shot
if you see is just like this yeah and so
this is this is clearly entirely
unnecessary commentary right
a nipple on to talk about how the
technology you know the right I don't
know how it didn't react properly on and
didn't actually sure she's early on I
really like Elizabeth had a super shitty
[Laughter]
Bay edit Bay like this with the mouse
and it's carpal tunnel wrist Honorius is
like oh my god what is this the name is
nipple that's funny it's like they
didn't it's like someone being prank
called not realizing that Seymour butts
is a fake name Seymour punch
don't ever call here again kid click but
someone ABC was like Chiron how do you
spell that it was no mo from The
Simpsons just like just like the part of
the breast but we got to you his name is
not documentary to use the name Elena
nipple is amazing
this has got to be a next role Anna and
do hit by the way the notification belt
I've hit subscriptions and hit all
notifications because subscriptions
don't mean a whole lot and please join
my club and I imagine total code corn
$30 off by the month of April okay $30
off for the entire month of April
quarantine alright okay we and there's a
good thing is that the back spasms town
I was laying on the couch in a weird way
we're yeah okay so I think I know this
is the last clip please yes it is
because I remember this specifically
this is the part of the video that you
saw and you guys haven't seen this so
you don't I I I'm almost at this point I
don't know if I'll be laughing cuz I'll
be curious as to if everyone here gets
why this is so funny
alright let's see if I can let's see if
I can hold it Elizabeth reacted swiftly
and harshly eliminating those who raise
doubts there were posts from employees
they equated it to the South American
dictatorship or a drug cartel they
assembled some of the best people that
they possibly could get and they just
vanished I was one of the few people
that stood up to her I told him no in
numerous occasions terrified I messed
her up everyone here was intimidated by
to cheat and Maddie but but I punched
her who was Bob named areola I did you
punched her right yeah why do you make
yourself out to be the tough guy
afterwards you I said no multiple times
I wasn't gonna be pushed around by big
old Elizabeth Holmes with her stupid
voice can you imagine a special where
there's just some guy from HR who just
like talking to ABC 20/20 going like
everyone else was was really scared
about from Elizabeth home about [ __ ]
her up I said boom zoom right to the
moon Elizabeth home they would never
just show a domestic abuser in sort of
like a caddy but ultimately kind of
guilty fun I said no multiple look I
think Amanda nips is great I think she
adds a lot Amanda a great character name
is evolving it's it's excellent and then
is it very less that we don't have a
clip but we have to go is I remember at
the end they say Elizabeth home being
Prison and it ends with a nipple saying
like should she go to prison let me just
say prison let me just say orange is
near black wrote a joke it's like you
spoke the title being renewed for three
seasons which is remarkable to me that
it's so popular that it's like on season
six and just I still go back and forth
with ABC just that tone-deaf or they
just thought we'd all be like yeah sure
okay or do you think that they were
saying we need to make sure that
everyone eventually says oh yeah sure
ng nipple thank you so much we will see
you Monday with good morning mug Club on
the rest of free mug club month mukluks
quarantine
[Music]